cloud nine's economy skadoodle unable to
escape standing over the seas and they
can't work fast enough what is going on
in this round they're losing the a site
they're getting absolutely annihilated
it's almost a moment where you think all
right no mistakes can be made now
because you don't want to hit that match
point where you really can't make any
more mistakes now you know
they cannot surely they cannot witness
they've got to run away they have to run
away they've got all the kills but they
will win the round
[Applause]
we had lost around but everyone in comms
said we have this we got this come back
nothing else is going on he's got to go
back stewie's on his own but look at him
climb look at that time there's
definitely
[Applause]
over time
before we get into this video i wanted
to remind you that every second counts
is brought to you by cisco powering the
future of esports
now cloud nine were not supposed to be
in the grand finals of a major
it wasn't their fault though it's not
like cloud 9 were a terrible team or
anything in fact they were among the
best north american cs go had to offer
but that didn't mean a lot
internationally to me i would say
international
perception and sentiment probably wasn't
great around nacs it was too back and
forth
maybe we'd have one good event here and
there but it wasn't something consistent
so going into the boston major hopes
weren't exactly high for c9 and they
barely squeaked into the bracket stage
after a rough group stage
should be planted out and open plan of
that quiet game for skadoodle by the way
six kills
against this
unlikely based on that stat line but it
would be the best thing he's done all
game
flashed off in the open completely
wrecked as well g2 16-8 there is the
peak there's the flashback very
important outcomes antares gets nothing
down to pass picks rush out the air now
another one from paz what else could he
oh my goodness paz fought from him
absolutely unbelievable there from him
oh my god the ace to take the match for
us we started off o2 and i remember
having this conversation with our team
that
you know these first two matches that we
played is not our game it's not we're
not playing our game we're trying to
anticipate the other team so on these
next few games let's make sure we're
focusing a lot more on ourselves and you
know making sure we're losing
because we messed up you know not
because we're trying to make reads or
anything like that cloud nine persevered
though shocking the world with wins over
g2 and sk to make it into the grand
finals cloud9 answering back twice as
hard taking down
automatic with the kill and just like
that
clown nine in a one versus four
taco can't do anything the pandemonium
is 16 rounds and cloud9 are in the grand
finals of a major tournament
but their confidence was shaken by what
was happening on the other side of the
bracket great read from zeus to hold off
as well because he knew ct was kind of
so the event was nest life let's
likely i should say what a shot from
guardian words out of my mouth as he
nails it through the box he is tagged up
smoke on the bomb immediately he's got
the kit doesn't elect to hold on to it
yet he's got time to play with and two
for two smoke will do it's phased to the
final and guardian is an absolute god
faze clan were cs goes super team not
only were they among the favorites to
win at all they were looking unstoppable
in the bracket after demolishing mouse
sports and navi bays looked unbeatable
but behind the scenes things were a
little more complicated we're not
surprised to see faze because they were
on a super hot streak what we did feel
going into that finals was that we were
starting to win scrims against faze it
just felt like those scrims were way
more competitive than the matches were
against faze leading up to the event so
it just made us think like we obviously
have the skill to hang we just have to
bring it during the actual game on stage
but to the crowd watching in the arena
and twitch on grand finals day these
were the clear favorites you can see
cloud9 have certainly not had the best
of it faze clan seem to be their
kryptonite bay's not only won the last
three encounters in the best of three
two and all it's in such a dominant
fashion as you guys could see only
double digits two times for cloud9 so
they have no reason to be scared of
anything whether it's cloud9 whether
it's the crowd yes cloud9 is playing
super well but faze is the favorite here
and they're going to play like it three
versus three the bomb is down automatic
still on the a site for some reason
maybe looking for a lurker this is
absolutely kind the smoke's going away
and now it's olive by some of the sniper
there's guardian automatic on his own
running up a short position i think all
of might have heard him which means that
they can all hold angles the smoke fake
the flashback won't work out face plans
take the first map of this series we
lost and we were walking off stage and
for me there's a lot of emotions running
you know major finals biggest you know
tournament of our career right now we
went in there not the same as we were
before a little bit you know our
communication wasn't the best our energy
wasn't flowing um we weren't really
playing
our game the best we can and you know
walking off the stage it was more so
you know thinking that you know we don't
want to waste this opportunity we want
to put everything out in the server we
want to leave the leave the server
knowing that we have no regrets faze
took map one but c9 fought back and made
a huge upset on overpass olive meister
not close enough to deal the damage and
automatic can reset the situation is
tarik waits patiently
[Applause]
that is phenomenal clown nine make it
work
maps two in the bag and now they're back
in it it all came down to map three
inferno c9s major hopes were on the line
and at first things looked really bad
until stewie2k made one
impossible play the molotov comes in but
so does the rotation olofmeister though
has been taken out towards the b
bombsite but also automatics going
towards saying nothing else is going on
he's got to go back stewie's on his own
but look at the time look at the time
there's seven seconds of blood they're
trying to build pyramids but there's no
more play
stewie round we're going to overtime
let's rewind this map a bit and recap
how we arrived at stewie's incredible
clutch map 3 looked pretty close at the
half 8 to 7 for faze clan but then faze
went on a tear winning three in a row to
go up 11-7
cloud 9 took round 19 which should have
been good but that reset their loss
bonus and they won it after faze planted
the bomb meaning it wasn't too bad for
faze's economy without the loss bonus
cloud9's economy was rough and they got
destroyed in round 20.
take it down towards speedway in the
meantime and rush trying to hold down a
pit but he can't do it tariq he's going
to go through the smoke he is trying to
stop the postpone positions but guardian
will puncture his chest with phase just
four rounds from winning the major cloud
nine were running on fumes
cloud9 on the buy once again but it's
far from my deal skadoodle not on a
sniper rifle he's on a max 7.
that is that's not a very fun prospect i
gotta say bring another mag seven
jeffy a sign of desperation you're
absolutely right focus from faze clan is
cloud nine's economy skadoodle unable to
escape standing there with a season he
can't throw it fast enough what is going
on in this round they're losing the a
site they're getting absolutely
annihilated by faith clan
reminding cloud9 do you know who we are
and if the club's money they don't have
any money this could not happen this is
the worst possible time for it to happen
but in round 24 with their backs against
the wall c9 began to fight back face put
the brakes on and that's really
important that they still have the focus
to do that because that could have
easily collapsed around them really
badly
tariq begging someone to peek from the
balcony position and now two threads
being spotted towards the arch area but
automatic is hunting
nico getting tagged a flying match seven
are you serious
it's five versus one they haven't lost a
single player how on earth are they
doing this cloud night
again against all the odds back against
the wall they somehow find something
something very special indeed
still the underdogs
four rounds away faith clan trying to do
damage any kill here for faith stan is
huge because cloud9 don't double the
catch really
stewie2k waiting
baiting and eliminating
11 rounds of cloud9 and they get the
grenade down
guardian drop the gun and pick them in
advance here comes the molly he's gonna
do the flat off though and guardian
tries to escape he makes it towards the
oranges and the hc grenade but this is
only one player and he's still alive
three hp cloud niner at the point of no
return the bomb is far too tight they
cannot surely they cannot win this
they've got to run away they have to run
away they've got all the kills but they
will win the round it's match point face
even though they lost the round it was
absolutely pivotal to c9's comeback but
we had killed all of them and we saved
like an op and maybe another gun that
was a hugely critical round because we
had lost around but everyone in comms
said we have this we got this comeback i
remember almost everyone on the team
saying that i felt that just because
like their money was broke
we were kind of we just lost that round
based off of small little mistakes and
we felt super comfortable while giving
up matchpoint instead of heading into
what should have been a major winning
round faze had to force by rush to alive
four versus three to spotting one player
maybe two towards the other position
that otherwise is on short but it's a
flash and he's taken down carrick is not
done with this major yet here it is
they stay alive for one more round
guardian has the awp cloud9 two plays
towards ct they've got flashes of their
own they need to keep these players
blind they've got to smoke they can
close the distance but guardian has a
sniper rifle and they're playing for the
major this is one of the strongest ways
to play a post plot a sniper rifle
indeed guardian he whips the first shot
they start to march forward faze no this
is their chance they could steal it away
from cloud9 the flick shot miss guardian
in the most pivotal moment it has to be
kerrigan it has to be the leader but
it's rushed all the way in cloudmind
again
again they stay alive
faze were forced to save for round 29
their economy was in shambles and the
round was a slaughter it seems it will
be four versus two on the b bomb site
olofmeister trying to keep around the
smoke but look the rotation is being
pulled automatically coming off his
position the smoke the flashes automatic
slides do you need to land some shots
any years two kills for him
don't take out your teammate
he's gonna stay alive now 10 seconds for
this bomb to go down he must stay alive
stewie is going absolutely crazy on the
b bombsite there's
[Applause]
which brings us to the pivotal round 30.
rush of the north angle looking towards
the uh at position the molotov comes in
but so does the rotation on meister
though has been taken out towards the b
bombsite but also automatics going
towards saying nothing else is going on
he's got to go back stewie's on his own
but look at the time look at the time
there's seven seconds of blood
they're trying to build pyramids but
it's no more play stewie's wondering
around we're going to overtime like all
great plays this one started long before
this round began let's break it down
second by second with their economy
halfway in the toilet faze rolled up to
the round with a little less than a full
buy guardian has no helmet kerrigan's on
a ump this is what they're fighting for
the major with however it is phase clan
it doesn't matter what they have it
doesn't matter if they've got kevlar or
if they are naked if they've got rifles
or if they've got pistols they are
always capable of taking a round down
without utility they couldn't re-attempt
the high-speed rush that had almost won
them the game a few rounds ago so faze
decided to take it safe and slow
olaf tossed a molly up banana revealing
some pressure up b in a bid to take
control of top banana or secure a pick
but stewie was already further away and
no one on c9 took the bait because
cloud9's coach had developed a unique
strategy one of the key things we
noticed
was that on their t sides across all
maps if kerrigan isn't allowed to get
his team in a far advanced position on
the map and also have a kill on the
board by then their team is very
loose on the actual
exec into a bomb site in even situations
following velen's strat c9 holed up in
corners waiting for phase to come to
them and with the clock ticking down
faze's passive play was about to catch
up to them phase began to rotate towards
b with just 20 seconds left on the clock
to push behind olofmeister with the bomb
while automatic went a leaving stewie
alone i don't remember exactly what the
communication was but i remember the
clock being very low and there was some
sort of action towards a so in my head
i had bananas smoked and i still haven't
opened b which is super strong so
bananas smoked i told him that i feel
super safe here i can hold it and it's
better if you just go abe olaf pushed
through smoke only to be immediately
domed by stewie but nico guardian and
rain were close behind
for a moment there's panic you know for
a brief moment there's panic and then
stu hits the first shot
sue has the second shot i'm behind him
watching him and when that second shot i
mean the oranges shot on on niko when
that happened i mean
it's all over it's just a culmination of
the fact that we have come back so often
this is another one of those moments and
now we're gonna win the whole damn thing
the molotov comes in but so does the
rotation olofmeister though has been
taken out towards the b bombsite but
also automatics going towards saying
nothing else is going on he's got to go
back stewie's on his own but look at the
time
with seven seconds left on the clock
stewie caught guardian but that one was
a freebie guardian was baiting himself
to reveal stewie's position behind new
box stewie then slid behind cover only
to peek out again and catch nico on top
of first oranges this is the moment it
all could have gone wrong stewie only
had a fraction of a second to adjust his
aim for nico's position and if nico had
pre-fired the angle or had backup from
rain he probably would have killed
stewie before he could get the shot but
rayne didn't have time to catch stewie
on the cross angle he had to plant the
bomb or the round was over either way
without backup niko fell to stewie and
stewie had a comfortable 3 second buffer
to turn and catch rain attempting to
plant when they were coming in to be
during this round i was i took a look at
the clock and after i took the first
shot in my head i thought the round was
over you know i'm taking my time they
have no time and actually re-watching
the round rain actually had time to
plant the bomb and i didn't even know
that i thought the round was done after
the first kill so after i killed the
first one i was taking my time and i was
trying to tell my team the whole time
there's no time there's no time don't
even peek don't do anything you know
there's no time at all and then
afterwards it just pretty much happened
if faze had even a few more seconds to
execute they could have won the major
right there and if c9 didn't hang on
round after round stewie wouldn't get
the chance to clutch stewie
single-handedly pushed the game to
overtime but that's not the whole story
he needed his coach to come up with the
strats that helped c9 take on faze clan
his teammates to make the plays that
kept the team alive in a desperate game
and of course faze to take the rounds so
slowly that they had no time to play
optimally you know stu's positioning was
so strong
the t's had used so many nades on map
control that they just had to rush into
b they didn't have time to do an exec or
the utility the time was low i mean that
you're gonna start making mistakes when
the time is low and you're trying to get
on the bomb site and stu just
capitalizes on that perfectly c9 went on
to win in an overtime full of incredible
plays it is a dance and now they concede
multiple angles turret going takes all
the fights are down guardian on 11 hp
reigns peaks and he gets the angle now
superior angle is there a diffuse for
the ct side the nine just yet they're
spamming the grenades they're touching
the bomb and now goes rain another bomb
that is trying to defuse it again but no
guardian gets taken down in the corner
with the awp do they realize this i
think he's been spotted now guys have a
smoker to play with he can delay them if
he can occupy their attention long
enough his teammates can make the play
just by staying there he's a threat
oh my goodness
it was automatic
you saw it from this position before he
cannot miss a single shot
guardian weights
patiently as cloud9 sets the push up oh
oh this happens they made it work cloud
nine are your a league major champions
there's not really many words you can
explain how you can feel and you know
that's just a memory in the back of our
heads and we made history they lifted
the trophies as the first and to this
day only north american cs go major
champions but behind the scenes the team
was already having issues cloud9 were
arguing on the way back to the hotel
they were all great friends but it was
clear to them that this team wasn't
going to work anymore a lot of the
butting heads happening how do you
actually why should you play a certain
way that preparation aspect how should
we approach scrims um
we weren't necessarily on the same page
as that so i think that was one aspect
of it none of those issues
showed up on the server though they
worked together to win an impossible
major for the home crowd that teamwork
much like stewie's 1v3 hold itself was
never going to happen again cloud9
wasn't supposed to be in the grand
finals they weren't supposed to hold on
and push phase to the limit and they
weren't even going to be a team anymore
a few months later the moment the series
the major it's all ephemeral every
second of the match every moment
backstage we never heard about every
decision it all created the perfect
circumstances for a play like this to
happen there's a good reason it was
almost csgo's play of the decade it's
the kind of play you'll never see happen
again and that's exactly why every
second counts
[Music]
in the next episode of every second
counts presented by cisco we're going to
break down the greatest comeback in
valorant history great breakthrough kill
but good work again asana is still doing
it but
he's here he's finally arriving he gets
sent backing nitro out of nowhere it's
about 100 thieves rallying to come back
against ascend
check it out on december 1st
you